ushers
[Music]
devastated by grief today they came
together to say goodbye
you were like the final piece in what
seems like an unsolvable puzzle and you
always found a way to make it right
it's like trying to finish that puzzle
without the most important piece it just
doesn't seem to work and I don't know if
it ever will
[Music]
hundreds of people packed out Taunton
Minster and the streets around it to pay
tribute to 19 year old Barnaby Weber
classmates remembering a funny kind
loyal friend talented they said at
everything he did especially sport he
really was like a brother to me he
really um
he really
told me everything I know I want to
remind everyone the message that he's
left us with
that we need to live life to our fullest
and be happy every single day and
cherish every moment with the people
that we love
also at the funeral was the family of
Grace Somali Kumar she was killed with
Barnaby as they walked home from a night
out in Nottingham last month 65 year old
school caretaker Ian Coates was also
killed that night three families now
United in grief our Ordinary Boy was
anything but that his ordinary was in
fact what made him extraordinary
we remain a family of four
it is one of us isn't here right now
and I'd ask you to join me and you'll
probably be pleased to stand up
because I'd like you to join me
I'm giving my beautiful boy one minute's
Round of Applause or cheer or whatever
you want to do while we remember being
Philip John Weber
the man accused of murdering Barnaby
Grace and Ian is provisionally due to go
on trial next year but for now the
Family Focus is on celebrating the life
of their son who so clearly lived his
life to the fullest
Rachel Venable's Sky News Taunton